ja das problem war nur irgendwann kam
dann halt die eltern runter und wollten
eben zum geburtstag gratulieren und der
bruder und die schwester die haben nicht
alle weil die haben wir sehen die ligen
haben sich darum gestellt und haben
angefangen heribert zwischen mit vom
kuchen erhalten
[Musik]
hätte was glaubt jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video ich bin heute mal
wieder nicht so ganz alleine am start
sondern habe diesen luther hier dabei
jonas geht mein name ist juli vom kanal
juli und ja heute ich schäme mich
eigentlich schon fast so darüber ein
video zu machen aber es ist eigentlich
auch mega witzig also ihr habt
wahrscheinlich auch die löschung lesen
es geht heute so um die lustigsten sex
unfälle
und ja der erste teil ist hier auf
meinem channel den zweiten teil findet
ihr bei juli auf dem kanal ja einen
neuen channel deswegen wärs mega cool
wenn ihr auch da drauf gehen würde also
nach diesem video den abonnieren würde
ist ein ziemlich guter kollege von mir
deswegen würdet ihr mit damit auch nur
super gefallen tun und checkt das dann
einfach mal aus also der zweite teil ist
bei ihm auf dem kanal aber wir fangen
jetzt erst mal an von smart punkt nummer
eins der spielte sich halt wieso das
meiste komische hier auf unserer welt in
amerika und zwar war das ein junge der
dachte sich so acht kommen wie es halt
die meisten jungen machen so oder halt
männer
ich mache mir mal so selber problem
dabei war nur er hat natürlich
abgeschlossen und nach weniger zeit oder
geraumer zeit schon damit an sich seine
mutter im zimmer daraufhin hatte er sich
dann so erschrocken dass er
aufgesprungen ist hat seine hosen
hochgezogen reißverschluss zu und dann
ist der reißverschluss nicht zugegangen
sondern hat sich verrannt in seinem ja
und nicht mal die mutter hat das dann
wieder rausbekommen sondern wir mussten
erst ins krankenhaus und die haben das
schon irgendwie daraus geschnitten keine
ahnung will ich gar nicht wissen
eigentlich alle ganz ehrlich das ist
doch so was von peinlich oder ich glaube
ich würde mich nie mehr in meinem leben
meiner mutter trauert die augen zu
treten oder um bei dem ersten gezwungen
ziemlich kein mann den er vielleicht auf
alle kennen könntet könnte es
genehmigungen 81 cm großen schauspieler
byrne troja der ist nämlich bekannt als
seine rolle mini me in den austin powers
filmen also sollten eigentlich einige
von euch doch kennen und sie ist
eigentlich immer so ein bisschen normal
für ex freundinnen sind die nehmen immer
rascher an einen und so hat es auch
minimis ex freundin gemacht und dabei
kann richtig lustige sechs tage raus
denn er ist ja ziemlich klein geraten
nicht leben aber dann kam den beiden hat
man auf die idee ja machen wir mal den
geschlechtern in der badewanne und seine
ex freundin hat also ein bisschen
ausgeplaudert dass er beim sex in der
badewanne beinahe ertrunken wäre weil
das so klein war und im schaumbad
verloren gegangen ist roma in gold
es ist eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich
so ein unfall aber man kann sich
eigentlich schon als unfall betiteln und
zwar wahlweise und jungen der ist halt
so am tag danach praktisch also der
hatte als seine freunde zu besuch und es
war nach zwölf uhren erst gerade 18
geworden und die eltern und der bruder
so und die schwestermarke schlafender
lag mit seiner freundin auf dem sofa und
anderen film geguckt und es war
irgendwie schon vier oder so an es wurde
auch schon langsam hält und dann dachte
sich die freunde so plötzlich acht
kommen jetzt ist es mal zeit für sein
geburtstagsgeschenk und dann haben die
da halt angefangen so ja das problem war
nur irgendwann kam dann halt die eltern
runter und wollten ihm zum geburtstag
gratulieren und der bruder und die
schwester die haben nicht alle war die
haben gesehen die liegender haben sich
dann umgestellt und haben angefangen
happy birthday zwischen mit vom kuchen
in der hand und moment ich zitiere er
hat dann daraufhin gegen seinen foren
geschrieben wo er diese geschichte
geschildert hat also wörter geschrieben
das sie dann wirklich ins zimmer kam
während ich noch tief in meiner freundin
steckt blöd gelaufen als nächstes geht
es um eine story wo eine frau beim arzt
war der eine karotte in ihrem hintern
fand ja es ist wirklich so es gibt ja
manche menschen die die finden das
irgendwie cool oder erregen wenn sie
sich irgendwelche obst oder gemüsesorten
in den allerwertesten stecken das wäre
für sie erregend oder keine ahnung was
das für die auch immer ist es ist
einfach unverständlich für mich
zumindest und wenn du dann als arzt oder
eine frau kommt mit einer karotte im
hintern zu dir und sagt ja es wäre in
ihrer wohnung auf dem glatten fußboden
aus groß stasi auf dem boden halt immer
so ein gemüse korb stehen haben ist sie
da halt zufälligerweise drauf gefallen
und die karotte ist halt hinten drin
gelandet scheiße wie dumm kann man sein
das ist ja noch dümmer als wenn du sagst
in der schule dein hund hat seine
hausaufgaben gefressen also ganz ehrlich
so dann sind wir jetzt auch schon beim
vorletzten punkt und dieser punkt oder
diese sache hat sich halt in italien
abgespielt steht ja so für romantik und
so und zwar wollte der frau unbedingt
mal was mit ihrem mann im mehrheit haben
das haben wir dann auch in die tat
umgesetzt nur irgendwie hat die dann so
ich weiß noch nicht genau was das ist
auf jeden fall vagina kampf oder so also
die steckten halt fest kannst du nichts
machen müssen die halt zusammen da
rausgehen sollte ich mal vor da sind so
ganz viele urlauber auch geil
sind dann ins krankenhaus und irgendwie
konnten die dann wieder voneinander
trennen aber trotzdem mega kacke oder
was alles für sachen gameplay schonhardt
zone
habt ihr auch schon mal irgendwie so ein
sex unfall mitbekommen schreibt wird auf
jeden fall morgen in die kommentare
wirklich mega interessieren also schon
ein bisschen als nächstes geht auch
wieder um so eine geschichte so ähnlich
wie bei dieser karotten story dieses mal
geht aber um einen mann der auch wegen
schmerzen in seinem hinterteil dann zum
arzt gegangen ist aber die erste konnten
nicht feststellen warum er diese
schmerzen hat also äußerlich war nichts
zu sehen
und wenn ihr gleich erfahrt was der sich
da hinten eingeführt hat oh je das ist
einfach nur verstörend die ärzte haben
dann eine röntgenaufnahme gemacht und
haltet euch fest was es war
es war eine bierflasche eine scheiß
bierflasche jetzt überlegt euch mal die
wahl von außen nicht sichtbar als eine
bierflasche ist ungefähr in diesem
ausmaß das ist doch gestört aber jetzt
muss man erst mal im kopf realisieren
wie groß eine bierflasche ist eine
bierflasche ist ungefähr so groß das ist
einfach nur geisteskrank die haben von
außen nichts gesehen und er hat auch
nichts gesagt ich denke es war eben auch
ein bisschen peinlich oder wenn das
vergessen hat das ist das ist dann
komplett bescheuert und ich frage mich
auch was tut dann als arzt zu deinem
patienten sax der gut herr soundso wir
haben eine röntgenaufnahme gemacht wir
haben eine bierflasche in ihrem haus
gefunden
ich kann es immer noch nicht realisieren
ja das war's mit diesem video chat auf
jeden fall den zweiten teil und in der
video beschreibung direkt der herzen
leben drauflegen der ist bei johanna und
julia eben auch schon gesagt und in
seinem konzept von jetzt an werden wir
sehen uns am nächsten sonntag wieder 18
uhr jetzt immer schönes waren euch noch
ist überhaupt nicht meine ferien also
ich habe vielen hobbys